hat vol ich schon ich bin arbeitsfähig
und bin viel zu stolz zum Amt zu gehen
du wirst bestraft wenn du arbeitest und
wenn du nicht arbeitest wirst du dann
noch
belohnt grüß schön ist gar nicht me so
dass sie sagen die Arbeit lohnt sich
nicht mehr die sagen wir bekommen unser
Geld trotzdem die Erhöhung des
Bürgergeldes einige wollen Sie
verhindern für andere wäre sie eine
lebensnotwendige Entlastung wenn ich da
jetzt drauf verzichten müsste dann wir
es richtig eng ohne diese geldch wäde an
die Straße
gelandet Arbeiten nah am Mindestlohn 13
€ pro Stunde 5 Tage pro Woche 5 Stunden
am Tag putzt Cornelia duchart im Auftrag
ihrer Reinigungsfirma in einem Kölner
Bürogebäude 940 bis 1000 € pro Monat
bringt ihr das ein statt der harten
Arbeit lieber Bürgergeld beziehen
darüber nachgedacht hat sie schon mal
das habe ich mir schon mal ausgerechnet
und habe dann also kurz zeitig
tatsächlich überlegt aufzuhören weil
wenn mein Verdienst zwischen 900 und
1000 € sich beläuft ich gezwungen bin
noch ein Minijob zu machen weil 8
Stunden würde sich nicht lohnen dann
käme ich damit nicht aus 800 € Miete
muss sie pro Monat für ihre kleine
Wohnung zahlen viel Geld für so ein
kleines Einkommen die Arbeit aufgeben
kommt für sie nicht in frage ich glaube
dass das auch mit der Einstellung des
Menschen zu tun hat ob ich auf
Staatskosten leben möchte obwohl ich
arbeitsfähig bin und ich bin
arbeitsfähig und bin viel zu stolz zum
Amt zu gehen also arbeite ich lieber
meine Teilzeit weiter suche mir noch ein
Minijob und damit komme ich einigermaßen
klar weil ich nicht auf Staatskosten
leben möchte manche ihrer Kolleginnen
haben aber anders entschieden wollen
lieber Bürgergeld beziehen und auch ihr
Chef hat dafür kein Verständnis das
Bürgergeld verschärfe den
Arbeitskräftemangel klagt holg eikolz
der Geschäftsführer vor allem
Teilzeitkräfte würden aufhören das sind
bei mir alleine in den in dem zehn
Betrieben pro Betrieb 5 bis Z
Mitarbeiterin Mitarbeitern im letzten
Zeitraum die einfach von der Fahne
gegangen sind im Januar soll das
Bürgergeld noch mal steigen das Problem
werde sich dann verschärfen vermutet
er die Anreize durch die Erhöhung werden
noch größer die Arbeit nicht mehr
auszuführen sonder sich lieber in die
sprichwörchliche soziale Hängematte zu
legen bitte nicht falsch verstehen ich
bin dafür jeder der nicht arbeiten kann
aus welchen Grunden auch immer mögen das
gesundheitliche Gründe sein Kinder oder
was auch immer die sollen ihr Geld
bekommen gerne auch ausreichend Geld
damit sie ein vernünftiges Leben führen
können dagegen sind aus meiner Sicht
alle die arbeitsfähig sind aber nicht
arbeiten wollen die sollte man sehr sehr
schnell in Lohn und Brot bringen und da
sollte man auch sehr schnell mit den
Kürzungen der Sozialleistungen anfangen
er betont die Reinigungsbranche zahlt
ungelernten 13 € pro Stunde ab Januar
13,50 € und damit mehr als den
gesetzlichen Mindestlohn für einige hier
offenbar zu
wenig panayota F teamu betreut für das
Unternehmen 42 Gebäude Schulen
Kindergärten Verwaltungsgebäude in drei
Monaten seien ihr drei Reinigungskräfte
abgesprungen mit der Begründung sie
wollten lieber Bürgergeld beziehen die
Arbeit bleibe dann an den anderen hängen
manchmal muss sie jetzt selbst
dran
diesen Unmut den man auch selber dann
entwickelt weil man sagt ich stehe jeden
Morgen um 5 Uhr auf um mein Geld zu
bekommen und die anderen liegen dann
noch im Bett und sagen geht die Arbeiten
finde ich eine burdenlose Frechheit wenn
ich das so sagen darf Denny fuhmann im
thüringischen Neustadt an der ora
arbeitet schon lange mit Menschen die
vom Bürgergeld Leben der Verein für
soziale Hilfe will sie in kleinen
Schritten wieder an die Arbeitswelt
heranführen wir brauchen
ungefähr zwe bis 5 Jahre um diesen
Prozess wieder umzukehren ja einfach zu
sagen wir sind jetzt wieder
soweit dass die Leute ich sag einfach
mal die Kleinen benimmlichreeln haben
aber um auch wieder soweit zu sein dass
man sagen kann die Leute können wieder
eine Arbeitsleistung erbringen mit der
sie draußen ihr Geld verdienen können
erst Hars 4 dann Bürgergeld Cornelia und
Frank ti brauchen seit Jahren Hilfe vom
stat seit d Jahren kommen sie hierher
wollen wieder
arbeiten weil ich nicht ein ganz nach zu
Hause sitzen möchte weil das mir so
langweilig zu Hause ist ich bra Bewegung
Beschäftigung
502 € Bürgergeld pro Monat bekommen
alleinstehende aktuell ab Januar steigt
der Satz auf 563 €. eine vierköpfige
Familie bekommt bisher je nach Alter der
Kinder bis zu 1793 € ab Januar dann 2011
€. oben drauf wird in der Regel auch die
Warmmiete bezahlt wenn die Wohnung nicht
zu groß ist
den furmann ist überzeugt das Bürgergeld
darf nicht zu hoch sein sonst verlieren
seine Klienten die Motivation zu
arbeiten mit dieser
bürgergelderhöhung wird die Spanne
zwischen Bürgergeld und jemanden der im
im Niedriglohnsektor für den Mindestlohn
arbeitet noch geringer und es ist ganz
einfach meiner Meinung nach ab einem
bestimmten Punkt ein reinreisches
rechenmell
wo man einfach sagen muss lohnt sich
arbeiten gehen oder lege ich mich
einfach in die Hängematte des
Sozialstaates haben wir do eine zweite
Decke ein ähnliches Projekt in Münster
Udo terling war lange arbeitslos dann
hat er hier beim Verein Chance als
rikchafahrer angefangen fährt Senioren
mit dem Rat zu Arzttermin mittlerweile
verdient er 900 € weil das zu wenig ist
bekommt er aufstockend noch 150 €
Bürgergeld würden die 150 € wegfallen
aus irgendeinem Grund das wä echt
Problem dann müsste man viel viel viel
sparsamer Leben als ich das ohehin schon
tue denn mit 1000 € im Monat
letztendlich die ich habe da kann man
keine riesen Sprünge von
machen bin no mal weg die Arbeit erfüllt
ihn bis Februar macht er deshalb eine
Ausbildung zum
Betreuungsassistenten danach könnte er
im Altersheim etwa Demenzpatienten
begleiten möbeltrödel im Sozialkaufhaus
auch hier hilft der Verein
Langzeitarbeitslosen wieder auf die
Beine die Forderungen aus Union und FDP
die anstehen bürgergelderhöhung wieder
zurückzunehmen für Geschäftsführer
reiner Wick schwer zu verstehen ist ein
Unding den Leuten jetzt wieder etwas
abzunehmen gerade in dieser Zeit wo
alles teurer geworden ist wo wir also
auch tatsächlich merken bei jedem
Einkauf was das Leben kostet Mitarbeiter
Toro seit September ist er raus aus der
Arbeitslosigkeit 1500 € brutto verdient
er hier als
vollzeitmöbelpacker das Bürgergeld das
er lange bezogen hat hat ihn gerettet
ohne diese Geld ich wäde an die Straße
gelandet und das ist nicht gut hier in
Münster sagen sie das Bürgergeld ist ein
Existenzminimum für die die es wirklich
brauchen denn es gebe nun mal Menschen
die Schwierigkeiten haben im Leben und
die Hilfe der Gesellschaft dringend
benötigen